The broadcast is now starting. All
attendees are in listenonly mode.
Good morning everyone and welcome to
Investor Expo show for March 25th. My
name is Anna and I'll be your host
today. We are having a great lineup of
four speakers for you. Michael Walos,
Steven Kawitell, Dan Pasarelli, and Alla
Peters.
This session will be recorded and sent
to your email. Please take a look at
your go to webinar control panel into
the questions box. You'll be able to ask
any questions you want during the
speaker
unmuted.
I would like to begin and bring to the
show our first guest, Michael Valtas.
Good morning, Michael.
Good morning, Anna. See, uh it's a nice
Thursday afternoon in some places. It's
about uh 10:00 here in Chicago. Let me
get my screen up here. Um,
okay. Hopefully you can see everything.
Okay. And the sound is good.
All is great. Uh, thank you. You have 45
minutes.
Excellent. Thank you. And uh, thanks
everybody for taking the time out uh, of
your busy schedule today. You know, the
markets are been pretty hectic week.
Honestly, it seems like every week is a
hectic week nowadays. And you know one
of the things is you know when the
market is at such high levels the
volatility is is greater the moves are
greater. So what I want to talk about
today is things you know that you should
know about orderflow. And really my my
goal today you know sort of what I want
to tell you about orderflow is how
simple it is and easy it is to use
orderflow in your trading. Now, what
attracted me to order flow years ago,
and I'm talking about, you know, well
over, you know, 10, 15 years ago, was
that I wanted to be able to see things
in the market that other traders didn't.
You know, I wanted to understand why a
market moved when there was no reason
for the movement. You know, sometimes,
you know, especially
nowadays, you know, electronic trading
is very fast, very quick, and you see
the markets just literally turn in a
second. All right. And we may not know
the reason why it turned, but if we
understand what's happening in the order
flow, we could say, "Oh, yeah. Now it
makes sense. I can see why the market
turned here." So order flow is based on
what's happening in the market right
now. And why is that important? It's
because you have to trade the present,
not the past. And what benefits traders
more is by analyzing what's happening
right now in the market because that's
based on what's trading right now,
right? You know, a lot of people like to
talk about their fancy um indicators,
their moving average, etc. But all that
stuff is based on price which happened
in the past, not necessarily what's
happening right now. Now, for those of
you that haven't got it yet, I'm going
to show you how to get a copy of my book
for free. It's called Trading Orderflow.
It's a 150 page uh book. You're not
going to get a hard copy. You're going
to get a link to the digital download,
but if you stay till the end, I'll show
you how to get it. Now, for those of you
that are new to who I am, my name is
Michael Valtos, and I've got over 25
years professional trading experience.
Now, when I say professional trading
experience, I don't mean I traded my own
account, you know, while I worked as,
you know, in another industry. No, I was
in the industry in the futures industry.
I started on the CME trading floor
literally as a runner. You know, that's
as low as you can start. And I worked my
way up from there. I spent about uh two
and a half years on the CME floor in the
currency quadrant. Then I left the floor
to work on the upstairs trading desk
when electronic trading started taking
off because you know what? I thought
that's where the future of the industry
is going to be and that's where I want
to be. Um and that was back in the early
1990s. After Dean Witter, I I joined EDF
man, the big English trading company.
It's been around since the 1700s. Spent
two years there on their global macro
futures trading desk. Then I left man to
join Culmer's Bank, right? The big
German bank. They opened an office in
Chicago and I was hired as a UX trader,
right? I traded buns, babbles, chats,
DAX, Euro stocks against all the US
products, right? Against the S&Ps,
against the uh 10-year notes, 5-year
notes, etc.
After Commerce Bank, I then joined
Cargill, right? The big US commodity
trading company. And it's, you know,
either the the largest privately held
company or I think some other company
just overtook it. But it's, you know,
they account for about 30% of the grain
exports of the United States, about 25%
of the meat exports, but they literally
trade everything that's tradable. And I
spent uh four years there. They sent me
out to Singapore to set up a trading
desk when the exchange in Singapore
closed. And after Cargill, I joined JP
Morgan. I spent eight years at JP
Morgan, vice president of futures
trading, you know, on the trading desk
trading, not sitting in an office,
looking at spreadsheets, coming out
every once in a while talk to the
traders. No, you know, I was the trader.
I was on the trading desk. After JP
Morgan, you know, after I got married,
after I had my first child,
I realized, you know what? This is not
what I want to do. I don't want to have
a heart attack working, you know, 12
hours a day, you know, in a bank. So, I
left JP Morgan and, you know, I knew how
to trade. So, I figured I'll just trade
for myself. And so, I started writing my
book on order flow, the book that you
get at the end. And I was trading with
the order flow already. But the software
that was out there, you know, I felt
lacking. Okay? It was just, you know, as
I was writing my book, you know, I
realized there's all these little
nuances of order flow that I said, you
know what, I could take all that
information, put it in a software rather
than just having your normal, you know,
footprint chart looking at the order
flow. I said, you know, let the computer
highlight certain things to me, you
know, what's happening in the order flow
to make my life easier. Okay? And the
platform that it runs on is Ninja Trader
8. So really,
you know, it was a transformation for
me, right? Because I I wanted software
that would help me in my analysis, make
my analysis a lot easier. But at the
same time, it didn't exist, right? There
was just your normal orderflow footprint
chart. But I said, you know what, let's
make something better. Right? Apple
didn't invent the the the mobile phone,
but they just took the existing
technology that was out there for the
phone and made it better, right? So, you
know, you're going to realize there's
more to just order flow than just delta
point of control and imbalances. And
again, the reason I just talk about that
is because the charts that are using in
this presentation are generated from my
orderflow software. But again, what I'm
showing you today can be applied to any
other footprint chart, but you have to
know what to look for, right? So, and
that's why I'm here to to teach you what
to look for. So, you'll see how easily
and quickly you can apply orderflow
analysis to your trading. So, you know,
just a brief disclaimer. You know,
stocks don't always go up. You know,
we're in a unprecedented time where it
just seems like, you know, anything you
buy goes up. Although, the last couple
days everything you buy just goes down.
But you know over the last you know
literally almost the last year we've
been on this tremendous bull run in the
market. So what is this about? Well it's
about orderflow is about taking the
different pieces of market information,
right? Imagine the market's like a
puzzle. You're trying to put the pieces
together and it's just like you pick up
this piece. Oh, okay. I see it goes
here. Then at the end of the day, you
know, hopefully you had a good day and
you put the the pieces of the puzzle all
together during the trading day and
you're able to come out ahead. So, you
know, your normal bar chart, right? This
is what most people look at when they
come to the markets, right? There
everyone's familiar with the normal bar
chart, but have you ever thought about,
you know, for a second where does that
information come from, right? where
where you know why why does the market
stop here you know and reverse up here
you know most people don't really get to
that point you know they just looking at
this and see oh well yeah the market
open at this price closed at this price
you know had a high and a low here but
they never really think about how it's
formed well it comes from the time and
sales right it's a record of every trade
that occurs on the exchange as it occurs
now time and sales has a time stamp okay
and it also tells you the price traded
and the quantity traded at that
particular time. But it also tells you
what people don't realize
is whether the trade was on the offer
side or the bid side. And that's very
important information. Right? When
honestly when I first started on
electronic trading back in the early
90s, um the Chicago Board of Trade on
their electronic trading system, they
had this little ticker that would run at
the bottom. And you know most people
myself included and everyone else on the
desk was like well why why do we need to
see you know what's going through but it
was really
important because you know on the
trading floor right in the days of open
outcry
you'd be able to see you know which bank
was buying or which big local was
selling and that was important
information and the board of trade was
the only firm at that time that had that
information available. So, you know, you
could see if there was a big offer, you
know, if um Solomon Brothers was the
offer and
if you're in the industry long enough,
you know that you know who Solomon
Brothers customer was generally trading
big size in the bonds and things like
that. So, that was important
information. Nowadays, you know, things
are more anonymous in in the sense that
you don't know who the big players are.
And the way execution algos are, they
really break up an order into the
smallest size possible, which is one
lot. Now, this is just a screenshot of
last night in the um uh MNQ, right, the
micro NASDAQ. And you could just see
like every trade that goes through is
like one lots, three lots. And it's it's
really hard to get an understanding, but
once you understand, well, did that one
lot or this three lot trade on the bid
or did it trade on the offer? You could
start to see, you know, if traders are
aggressive in the market. And all this
information, right, is not you're just
not really looking at it on a bar chart.
You're just looking at the price that
traded. But when you take it and you put
it on a footprint chart, you start to
get more information than just the open,
high, low, close, right? You're going to
get information like the delta, which is
the net difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers, right?
Remember earlier on on the time and
sales, right? You see different colors.
You see orange colors, you see green
colors. Well, if it's green
and orange, it tells you, you know,
whether someone is lifting the offer or
hitting the bid.
And that's going to show up on the
footprint chart. Excuse me. As well as
other information, right? as well as the
point of control, which is the price
level in the bar with the most volume.
You're also going to see imbalances, you
know, areas where there was more
aggressive buying than aggressive
selling or vice versa, more aggressive
selling than aggressive buying. And all
this information, delta, point of
control, and imbalances for the longest
time was really all that people looked
at in in the order flow. And you know,
it's good information, right? Because
it's imagine you have open, high, low,
close, which everybody looks at. But if
you can take it a little bit deeper,
right? Delta point of control and
imbalances. You're going to start to
understand how the market is trading.
You know, is it very aggressive or is it
less aggressive? Is the aggressive
trading getting stronger in a direction
or is it getting weaker in that
direction? You know, if it's getting
weaker in a direction, chances are that
that move is going to end. So, there's
all little things like that, right? So
just really quick, you know, the delta
is the difference between aggressive
buying and aggressive selling. You know,
how many buyers, how many people are
buying the offer versus how many people
are selling into the bid. Imbalances is
when your aggressive buyers outnumber
the aggressive sellers by 4:1 or more
and vice versa. Now 4:1 is not set in
stone. You can adjust that. You know,
some people use 5:1, some people use
3:1. Um, it really depends on your
trading style. So you can see right
already we're starting to look at really
what the aggressive traders are doing.
You know are aggressive traders buying
or selling? And you know a lot of people
they think that well you know for every
you know in the old days right people
you'd call your broker market's down 2%.
What happened? Well there was more
sellers than buyers. Well then no
there's not more sellers than buyers.
What you have is more aggressive sellers
than aggressive buyers, right? Because
obviously for every buyer there has to
be a seller. But when you have more
aggressive sellers hitting the bid,
taking out whatever is bid there, then
hitting the next bid, taking that out,
hitting the next bid, more aggressive
sellers than buyers to cause the buying
to go back up. Now, point of control is
simply the price level in the bar with
the most volume. Okay? And that's
important because often times depending
on where the most volume occurs in a
bar, it can be very revealing in terms
of market structure. you know, did the
market stop at this level or something
else happened. Okay, so you know, all
these little pieces, they start working
together and give you a lot of
information, but knowing what the delta
point of control and imbalances are is
one thing. You have to know how and when
to apply them to the market. You know,
it reminds me of
back in high school, right? Algebra,
right? You we're all sitting there in
our algebra class, our trigonometry
class. When am I ever going to use this
information, right? And you know all
these little pieces of information you
like delta point of control and
imbalances you we we know what they are
but a lot of traders just don't know how
to put the pieces together. Okay so this
was again yesterday in the MNQ right
you'll notice point A market sold off
and then rallied from there. Point B
market sold off rallied from there.
Point C
market rallied and then sold off from
there. Right? Have you ever thought
about how these levels form? You know, a
lot of people like to come up with,
well, you know, this is a
fib number. You know, there's a trend
line you can draw in from here. You can
literally draw lines from everywhere.
You know, I've seen people post charts
online, you know, on Facebook groups and
things like that, and they literally got
lines like every five points. And it's
just like, you know, then it hits that
level. Oh, yeah. See, I called it. Well,
yeah, you got every five points you got
a line. But when you're watching the
market trading in real time and you can
start to understand what's happening in
the market, you know, it just really
starts to make sense. So, let's break it
down. Okay, so point A, right? This is
that first area right here where we came
down um what was that about 12:15
yesterday in the micro NASDAQ, right?
12875. Then we reversed and started
rallying back up.
Well, as you can see what's happening,
right? Just on a delta basis, right? The
bar before it, right? Big down candle
down a red candle, right? Big negative
delta - 421. Then this next bar opens up
again. It's opened up and it's a big red
bar down, right? It's got a very strong
negative delta - 405 in the min delta
and that's telling you that aggressive
sellers were in control. But what
happened? market reversed, closed
higher, and you went from minus 405
negative delta to + 58. Now, plus 58
isn't the strongest delta number to land
on, but what did you have early on in
that bar? It was very strong negative -
405. Everyone was thinking, oh, this is
it. We're going lower, you know, we hit
875, next stop, you know, 800. All
right, but it reversed. So it went from
-405
all the way up to zero and then plus 58
where it closed actually went up to plus
71 is which is the max delta. Then we
closed at plus 58. So it went from minus
405 ate all that back gave back 405
aggressive sellers and took on another
71. So that's a big swing right. So what
was happening in this bar was very early
on the impression was that we were going
lower, right? And honestly it looked
like we were going lower
but no buyers stepped in. Aggressive
buyers stepped in and said no we're
stopping it at this level and market
reversed closed higher. Market took off
right it went back up
you know went all the way back up from
875 all the way up to what 9:30 and then
it sold off again. Okay, this time it
didn't get down to 875.
It just got down to 8 uh, you know,
around 8.87 and 886 and a half here.
Then it reversed and it went back up
again. Now,
what's happening this time around? Okay,
it's slightly different. Okay, we're
coming in, you know, we're coming in
hot, hot and heavy, right? It's got very
strong negative delta -300 - 533 but
then -27
then it turns positive 160 okay so delta
is decreasing - 500 right -27
right then it's positive okay well how
do you expect to go lower if we got
positive delta right well chances are
we're probably not going to go lower if
there's aggressive buying happening okay
then And the next bar confirms it with a
big strong positive delta plus 719,
right? And then we rallied from,
you know, the this 890
900 area all the way back up to 950.
Came off a little bit, started going
sideways, then came back up, poked a
little bit higher here at point C, and
then we sold off basically for the rest
of the day. All right, we sold off from
what is that the 940 950 area
all the way down, you know, 150 points
basically. But let's take a look at
point C. What's happening here?
Well, we're coming back up this is the
point C high right here. Okay, this big
red bar with positive delta. Okay, but
you know you I'm just you're thinking
we got positive delta.
Why isn't the market going higher,
right? You're thinking, well, Mike, you
know, you just said um you know, we we
can't go lower on positive delta, but
here we are going higher on positive
delta. Well, you sort of have to split
this bar in two here, right? Because
what's happening in this bar? Well, up
here you got some buying imbalances,
right? You got 19 against 83. It's a
little hard to see on this chart cuz
NASDAQ trades such big, you know, you
sort of have to scrunch it a little bit.
Um, you see, uh, seven against 21 or
sorry, three against 21. So, you got
some buying imbalances up here in this
red bar. Okay. So, you know, market is
rallying up. People are thinking, "Oh,
this is it. We're going higher. We're
going back up. You know, the market's
safe." Um, you know, stocks only go up.
And so, they're all piling in here,
right? But what you have happening up
here is you have supply in the market,
right? You have these big institutional
players that have a lot of supply on the
books. They're happy to sell it here at
850 or sorry, at 950, right? That's why
you have these inbounds because they're
they're stacking the order book. They're
working their offers up here, right?
They're providing liquidity into the
market that, you know, buyers are just
happy to gobble up. Once these buyers
gobble this up and they realize, uhoh,
we're not going any higher. It leaves
these imbalances in here, these buying
imbalances, market starts drifting
lower. You know, these people that were
buying up here at 949,
948 and a half realize, oh no, oh no, oh
no, no, no, no, no. The market starts
selling down, right? It starts coming
off. We're trading 44, 42, 40. They're
long from up here at 50, right? They I
got to get out now, right? Right? So
they start covering it down here. Bar
closes lower. Right? You still you're
still left with that positive delta
because you had that very strong buying
early.
All right. And then the market starts
trading down. Um obviously there's
things here in the order flow. There's
these what we call exhaustion prints
here at the top of these bars. Meaning
this move is is done. Stick a fork in
it. It's going to happen. You know, it's
just going to fall over. This is a very
bearish point of control um right here.
here. That's why it's colored red. But
really, the sign was in this bar. You
know, you have this big strong positive
delta. At one point, it was 252.
But you look at this bar, right? This
this is the thing, right? Where it gets
kind of misleading for people, right?
That you're thinking, well, you know, I
got a positive delta. Why isn't this
market going up? But then when you look
at it, you say, oh, now I understand why
the market didn't go up because I had
people the market just put in a rally.
We just took out our earlier high at
948, right? We pop back up here above
950. Oh, that's it. We're, you know,
we're breaking out. We're going higher.
Well, no. You know, these people are
trapped. There's caught off sides in the
market and then the market sells off. I
didn't expect it to sell off to new lows
and, you know, the rest of the day.
Expected it to come off, you know, at
least 20 to 30 points. But nevertheless,
you know, that was the clue that the
market gave you. And you could see it as
it's happening, as it's unfolding right
before your eyes. Now, this was crude
oil yesterday, right? You know, crude
oil, we hit this high and sold off,
right? Well, what's so special about
this high? Well, anytime you're up at
the high of the day,
you got to be asking, why are we here?
What's what's going on? you know, is is
but if you're looking at what's
happening in the delta, you're at your
high of the day and all of a sudden you
you're seeing selling come in, right?
Negative delta 138, negative delta 165,
then a small delta 11 33 25 more selling
right
here. Big negative delta minus 264,
right? And that's all coming in right in
here. You know, as you're at the high,
do you think this market's going to go
higher? If you see the aggressive
selling come in. No. And then we sold
off about 50 cents, right? Market
eventually came back up, you know, to
this high a little bit later about 130.
But you know, really what was happening
here, right? You could see the selling
coming in right all right in here,
right? In the negative deltas - 138, -
165, - 264. You know, you could safely
say, well, you know what? If it starts
to break down, you know, just, you know,
around here, I can get short, right?
Because, you know, what's my risk? My
risk is up here at the high, you know,
or even lower, you know, a little bit
off that high. But as you hit that high,
what happened? You attracted sellers
into the market,
right? Then you can just see, right, the
market sold off. It sold off all the way
down to the 60 area and it came in here,
right? market rate. You this was sort of
that that lowish area. But if you're
looking at the volume, right, you can
see that big heavy volume going through.
This is more of an advanced concept,
right? You can see the point of control
down here. But you can see this volume,
right? 115, 132, 126. Even earlier as
we're coming down, we're running into
some liquidity to support this market.
161, 148, 143, 162, and then in this
bar, 115, 132, right? Easy. You have
this sort of this area here where the
market goes back up, comes back down
into this area between 68 and, you know,
and what is that? 58. This 10-cent range
is your support, right? We came back
into that level. Then, you know, the
market went back up again, made a new
high by a tick. One tick, new high.
You know, sometimes people get excited.
We're start going back up to the high of
the day. Okay? You know, thinking this
is it. We're going to break out, go
higher.
What happens? Nothing. One tick high.
Then the aggressive selling reappears,
right? We're up here at the high of the
day. High of the day. Just made a new
high. But what do you have? Aggressive
selling - 144 - 136 - 350. Okay. Not
exactly the most encouraging thing, you
know, as a trader to see at the high of
the day is aggressive selling in in the
sense that if you're at the high of the
day thinking the market's going higher,
you do not want to see aggressive
selling creeping into the market at
strong levels. And
the thing is, you just use your brain to
see, well, yeah, okay, is this a strong
minus 144 negative delta? Yeah,
considering that the previous bar was
128, the previous bar was 36, previous
bar is 132, you know, as you're at the
high. So, what you have here is you got
negative delta that's stronger than any
of these previous deltas. You got to go
way back here, you know, 10 minutes
earlier to find any delta that's a
little bit stronger. But what you have
now is you got the aggressive sellers
coming into the market thinking, you
know what, this is a great opportunity
to get short. Okay, E- Minis yesterday.
All right, market sold off, rallied back
up and just sort of hung around here,
right? Then we sold off another 10
points, you know, rallied back up,
took out that high, you know, then sold
off. But what was so special about this,
right? This was a quick move down right
here. You see these bars, one, two,
three, four bars where it just dropped
10 points. I mean, it just sort of
rallied up here, sort of did nothing,
went sideways, and then dropped, right?
then rallied back up. Well,
what you had earlier at that level at
around the 14 level is what's called a
stacked imbalance, right? Where you have
aggressive sellers, right? What's an
imbalance, right? An imbalance is where
you have more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers if it's a stacked
selling imbalance
by a ratio of 3:1. But that's just an
imbalance. But when you have a stacked
imbalance, that means you have
three imbalances stacked neatly on top
of each other. And you can see it right
in here, right? This 584 against 75,
103 against zero, 456 against two,
right? So you got three imbalances all
stacked neatly on each other. I mean, a
lot of times you have bars that have
imbalances,
you know, and often times you can see
they're spread out right here, these
buying imbalances, right? Here's three
imbalances, but they're not stacked on
each other. Here's just two imbalances
stacked on top of each other. It's just
one. But when you have three,
you know, it gives it I don't say it
gives it more weight, but you know,
that's sort of the area where, you know,
things get interesting in terms of order
flows because what's happening, right?
When you have three levels or more, I
mean, it could be four, it could be
five,
but what you have is often times is you
have a quick move, right? Somebody's
wanted, you know, there's a big order
going through the market for whatever
reason that they want to fill, right?
And it leaves what's called a stacked
imbalance.
And oftentimes you see the markets, you
know, come back and test those levels,
right? Because
if you had aggressive sellers at one
point, well, chances are if we get back
to that area, you want to know if those
aggressive sellers are coming back into
the market. And what happened is it
rallied, sold off, rallied all the way
back up to that level and then sold off
again,
right? Sold off 10 points.
So, you know, you you can see how
orderflow can help you as a trader, but
you know, a lot of people, they think,
oh, you know what, that's great, but
it's too complicated. I'll never
remember how to do it all. So, what I
want to show you today is to make it as
simple as possible, right? I want you to
focus on one thing. All right? Bars with
multiple imbalances that are not neatly
stacked on top of each other. Now, I
just talked about a stacked imbalance,
right? Where you had
all right, three imbalances stacked
neatly on top of each other. But what if
it's not stacked neatly on top of each
other? What if you have a bar with three
imbalances,
but they're spread out, right, in a bar?
Well, does that mean they're not
important because they're not stacked on
top of each other? Well, no. I mean,
they're still important, if not more
important, right? Because one, everybody
is looking for stacked imbalances. You
know, everybody knows what stacked
imbalances are that that uses order
flow. I mean, that's one of the the
basic trade setups that people look for,
stacked imbalances. But what people
don't look for, for some reason, I I
don't get it myself, they don't look for
those bars that have multiple buying
imbalances that are spread out, right?
They may not be stacked neatly on top of
each other. Like here's one, right? Two
against 237, 5 against 203, 19 against
98. They're not stacked neatly on top of
each other. There's they're spread out.
But what you have is you have aggressive
buying being spread out throughout the
bar, right? Causing imbalances in the
bar. And that's important because
people some, you know, they're just not
looking for that. But you you have that
aggressive buying in the bar. Now, this
is ES E- Minis yesterday, right? All
right. Remember, we opened up, cash
opened here around the the 14 level,
rallied all the way up to 24, sold off
back down to, you know, the the 10 11
level. But why why does it reverse here?
Why does it reverse here? Well,
if you're looking at a footprint chart,
you would understand why, right? You can
see these imbalances in here, right? The
bottom of this candle, um 182 against
40, 172 against 13, 15 against two, 198
against 7, 59 against two. All right.
Even this other bar here, you got 1 2 3
4 imbalances. Two are stacked here. Then
you five. One here, one here, one here,
two here. Even this next bar 1 2 3 4 5
these are not these are spread out also
right but what if there was a way to say
you know to highlight to you that hey
you know you got these multiple
imbalances you know pay attention to
what's happening in the market right and
that's you know when I created my
software that was one of the things I
wanted to have in there it's like you
know what I'm I'm watching so many
different markets and when one market's
moving chances are some of the other
markets are moving and it might be um I
say difficult but it might be hard to
notice some of these little things. So I
said, why don't we put a signal on the
chart to tell me, hey, you know what?
You've got imbalances happening here,
multiple imbalances in a bar, right? So
what we do is we put a box around it,
right? To highlight that to you, just,
you know, cuz we're visual,
you know, we are so used nowadays to
Facebook and Instagram just, you know,
scrolling through our timeline, so to
speak, and seeing, you know, images and
and reacting to those images, right? the
the mind processes images at a much
faster rate than numbers. Okay? So, I'm
not necessarily
concerned about what the numbers are in
the bar in the footprint. I'm concerned
are there imbalances, right? And I can
see one, two, three bars here out of the
four that have multiple selling
imbalances. Okay? That's my clue that
hey, you know what? Up here, I got
aggressive selling coming in, right? I
can get short, right?
just by seeing that. All right, just by
seeing, you know, something so simple.
All right, then what happened? The
market sold off. We hit this area down
here around 10. Now, this is a prominent
point of control. I'm not going to talk
about prominent point of controls today
because that's a whole another
uh training session, but you know, I've
got a lot of videos on on YouTube
talking about prominent point of
controls. But what do you have in this
bar?
Right? You've got one, two, three, four,
five, six imbalances. Now, they're not
stacked on top of each other. Right? You
got a space in here. You got two price
levels here. These two are stacked on
top of each other. Then another two
normal orderflow volume levels going
through. Then another two imbalances.
And if you're just looking for stacked
buying imbalances, you're going to miss
this. All right? You're not going to see
this bar, which is very bullish,
right? But if you have something that
could highlight it to you, something so
simple. All right? Again, it's it's not,
you know, some fancy blackbox
mathematical equation that you're not
going to understand. You you understand
the idea of imbalances, right? You
understand the idea of stacked
imbalances. What this is is just it's
imbalances
in a bar that are not stacked neatly on
top of each other over a certain level,
right? Over 3 to one. You could adjust
it if you want to have bars with four
imbalances that are not stacked on top
of each other or five um or even two,
right? Depending on the type of chart
you're trading. Say you're trading a
really fast chart, you know, a 233 tick
chart, you know, maybe you want to use
two levels of imbalances. So, you know,
there's a lot of flexibility with it.
But again, if you're not looking for it,
you're not going to see it, right? So
remember, the information you see on
your bar chart comes from what's traded
in the market, right? From what you see
in the time and sales. But a candlestick
chart leaves out the most important part
of that data is the volume that's traded
on the bid, the volume that's traded on
the offer, but more importantly, how it
traded. Was it aggressive? Was it your
just normal order flow? Right? Markets
exist to facilitate trade. Right?
Markets exist to for people to transfer
risk from one party to another.
again yesterday in the E- Minis, right?
We we come up here, we just sort of go
sideways, then we start falling apart
here around this 24 25 level, right? And
we sell all the way down to 0405,
right? Rally, put a half-hearted rally
back up, sell off again, and then rally
back up. And if you remember, this was
that area where where it sold off in
here, right? This was that stacked
selling imbalance here. Okay, you know,
that's all well and good, but would you
rather be short from, you know, the 12,
sorry, the 13, 14 area, or would you
rather be short from 26, 25, 24, right?
When we saw all the way down to 04, you
know, that's an extra 10 points that,
you know, if you're looking at just
stacked imbalances, you're not going to
pick it up, right? And what do you have
here? Right? This is that area right in
here in this circle right up here. This
is this red bar, right? And what
differentiates what makes this red bar
so special than this one or this one or
this one or this one? Well, it's got the
multiple selling imbalances. 777 against
31, 39 against 7, 191 against 39, and
then two bars later, another three
selling imbalances that are not stacked
on top of each other. Right? So, you're
going to miss it if you're only looking
for stacked selling imbalances,
right? Then the market sold off, right?
We sold off again. That's from
this first bar is happening around the
25 area, 25 26. Then this even this next
bar, you know, 20, what is that? 21 to
24. Okay, say you miss it up here and
you catch it here. Okay, you're getting
short from 21, you know, 20 worst case,
all the way down to 04. Then you come
down to 04, right? Your market's selling
off. You're starting, you're still
seeing selling imbalances, bars with
multiple selling imbalances. That's what
you expect to see in a market selling
off. But then it hits this area, comes
in, boom, goes sideways, 1, two, three
bars. But in this third bar, what do you
have? Multiple buying imbalances. All
right, you got one, two, three, four,
five bing imbalances. All right, then
the next bar, one, two, three buying
imbalances. Now, none of these are
stacked binding imbalances of three or
more. So, if you're looking again just
for stack buying imbalances, you're
going to miss this, right? You're going
to miss this. So, you're going to miss
that move
right here back from 08 all the way back
up to, you know, 16, right? Okay. So,
you're going to miss this move down,
miss this move up, right? Now, I'm not
saying, you know, you'd sell up here and
cover it down here. You'd sell it here,
probably cover somewhere down in here.
Um, then you see this multiple buying
imbalances. You get it here, you cover
up here. I'm not saying you'd buy at the
low, sell at the high, but there's
chunks of market activity that you can
get.
So, you know, just fair warning, don't
just go out and start trading every bar
that has multiple imbalances in them.
you know, put them in context of the
market, right? Always trade in context
of the market. That's what being a
trader is. It's not just about red
light, green light systems. You know,
you want to be looking for a reason to
sell when we're at our high. Don't come
in thinking, oh, I got to sell at a
high. If the market tells you, oh,
there's aggressive selling coming in at
this high, okay, that's great
information. Or if you're at a low or
the low of the day, swing low, whatever.
But the market is showing you that, hey,
you know what? The aggressive buyers are
coming in. got a lot of buying
imbalances coming in here telling you
traders are scooping up this, you know,
these low prices, you know, take
advantage of it. That's what putting in
context of the market is. Just don't go
out blindly trade every bar that has
multiple imbalances.
Crude oil, right? What's going on down
here, right? We're just, you know, we
sell off. Boom. Then we just sort of go
sideways in here. Then we rally a dollar
yesterday, right? All these charts are
from yesterday. Well, as we sold off
here, right, all of a sudden, one, two,
three, four bars
with multiple buying imbalances. None of
these are stacked imbalances, right?
They're all spread out in the bar. So,
you know, if you think that, well, you
know, stacked imbalances are the way to
go. I'm thinking take it a step further.
Look outside the box. Look for those
bars with multiple buying imbalances.
Now, again, you don't have to have my
software to see this. You can look at
the chart with your own eyes, but having
software that's going to highlight it to
you just makes it that much easier. You
know, when traders first learn about
order flow, they learn what delta, what
is, what point of control is, what
imbalances are, but then they're sort of
left to figure out on their own how to
use those pieces of information. Again,
what's the point of having information
if you don't know how to use it, right?
This was crude oil this morning, 7:45.
Boom. We had a couple bars here. We came
into a swing low. aggressive buyers
started coming in. E- minis this morning
3:50 in the morning, we had a 10-point
selloff from 94 down to 84. Why
multiple imbalances, right? What makes
this red bar different from these is
this is the bar with the multiple
imbalances. These didn't have anything.
Even these green bars, nothing special.
No multiple buying imbalances. So,
what I just showed you can be done by
looking at
any footprint chart, but you need to
know what to look for and when to look
for it. Honestly, when the market's
moving, especially like yesterday, even
today, right? When the market's down
hard, it's easy to overlook things and
miss things. Let your trading software
do some of that heavy lifting and show
you things in the market like market
weakness or market strength. Right?
Signs of aggressive buying is market
strength,
right? Orderflow is about taking the
information that you see that you have
access to and putting it into an easy
read format. So, you know, in this past
40 minutes, you know, hopefully you
agree it's time well spent, but you
can't cover everything in, you know, a
40minut or 60-minute training session,
but I got a special offer for you so you
can get up to speed and learn everything
you need to know about orderflow as
quickly as possible. All right,
orderflow is a great way to trade the
market. Now the orderflows trader
software right the software I developed
it runs on ninja trader 8 it doesn't run
on sierra chart it doesn't run on trade
station runs on ninja trader 8 because
it's very easy and stable program um to
trade with and it's
a volume footprint chart with 17
pre-programmed tools right I just talked
about multiple imbalances so there's
another 16 tools on there for you it
takes 2 minutes to set up right you
don't need fancy templates or anything
like that um really just plug in,
import, you put Ninja Trader on, put
this the Orderflow Trader software on,
and you're basically set.
Normally, I sell this for $8.99 on my
website by itself. Just the software
itself is $8.99. But it's really like
the software. The best way to describe
it is like taking everything from my
brain that I've learned, you know, in 25
years of institutional trading and
putting it into a program to help you
dissect and understand what's happening
at the market. If you're looking for a
red light, green light system, this is
not for you. You know, this is for
people that want to understand what's
happening in the market. But having
software is one thing. You know, need to
know how to use it, right? I mean, I've
bought software in the past, you know,
all sorts of different softwares. And,
you know, I don't know how to use it. I
just give up, right? So, I provide you a
lot of extra education to get you up to
speed on not just how to use the
software, but order flow in general. So,
I give you access to my orderflow
trading course. You're going to get it
for free. You can buy it on my website
for 297, but I'm going to give it to you
for free. I'm also going to give you
access to my inner circle video series,
right? There's 56 videos in there of
advanced orderflow um tips and analysis
and and tricks, you know, different ways
to read the information that is
presented to you in the order flow.
So, you start adding all that up and you
know, it it starts, you know, people
say, "Oh my gosh, it's 1693, but you're
not going to pay that today, right?" And
the other thing I want you to realize,
right, it's one thing to learn from
videos, but it helps to have some sort
of handholding live training um
available to you. So, every Tuesday
night, and I've been doing this for over
two years, probably close to two and a
half years, I do a live training session
every Tuesday from 7 until 8:00 p.m. on
Tuesday night, Central time, and I talk
about things I saw in the market and,
you know, about order flow in general,
right? And if you want to come in, you
got to ask me a question about
something, I'm there for you, right?
It's your time to spend with me. We can,
you know, I talk about all sorts of
things, time for you to ask questions,
things you're stuck on. And if you can't
attend, you know, there's a archive that
you can go to. You know, some people
charge extra for this, right? I mean,
what's the point of buying software than
having to pay extra for training, right?
That should be included in there. So,
you know, you start adding it all up and
it's close to $2,000, but you're not
going to pay that. you're just going to
pay $7.49 today, right? It's a onetime
payment. It's not a recurring payment
that you can't cancel or anything like
that. It's just $7.49. Of course, you'll
still need to pay your data fees. So,
you know, a lot of people say very nice
things about the software. It helps them
understand the market.
So, what you do is you go to
orderflows.com/off3
and you scroll down to the bottom of the
page and it takes you here. You just
click that button to get started. Takes
you to PayPal. PayPal processes your
payment. And again, to get started, go
to orderflows.com. So, you got to figure
out what motivates you in life. Where do
you want to be? All right. For me,
freedom. All right. Be able to do what I
want to do when I want to do it. That's
what trading provides me. Now, as a
special bonus for investors expo and
give you access also to my orderflow
playbook, right? It's it's an additional
training. You're going to get it for
free. All right? So, go to
orderflows.com3.
You're going to get all this here. The
orderflows trader software, the trading
course, inverse circle video series,
live weekly group training and you're
going to get the orderflow playbook. So
to get my book, go to
orderflows.com/book.html.
Takes you here. Enter your name and
email. Hit submit. Takes you to the
download page. So again, to get started,
go to orderflows.com/ft3.
Anna's already put it into the chat, but
I'll also put it in there along with the
link for the book. And you know, I'm
right tight on time, so I'll I'll throw
it back to you, Anna. If anybody's got
any questions, just shoot me an email.
You know, it's just mike@orderflows.com.
It's my email. But um thanks Anna. I
I'll give it back to you so you get the
next speaker on.
Thank you so much, Michael. Great
presentation.
Thank you.
Let's move on and bring to the show our
next guest muted
Steven Kito.
Hello Stephen.
Hey, can you hear me?
Yes. Uh the sound is good. The screen
looks